In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Srinaksadiyun for July 25 on which we commemorate our righteous
Mother Olympia, the Deaconess, blessed Olympias was born in Constantinople between the years
361 and 368, into a family of the high aristocracy. Her father, Count Salukus, and her mother both
having died while she was still a child, she was placed under the tutelage of one of her
kinsmen, Prokopios, governor of Constantinople, who entrusted her education to theodosia,
sister of St. Amphilocius of Econium. Through her mediation, Olympias became friendly with St. Gregory
the Theologian, St. Gregory of Nisa, and other eminent churchmen. Reaching adulthood, she shone
both by her physical beauty and her wisdom and piety. In the year 386, she married Nebridius,
the prefect of Constantinople, who died shortly afterwards before having consummated the marriage.
She then decided to consecrate the rest of her life to the Lord as both widow and virgin and to
place her immense fortune at the service of the church. As she had refused to contract a second
marriage with Elpedius, a kinsmen of Emperor Theodosios, the state confiscated her possessions
and prevented her from visiting churchmen until she submitted. But, on his return from a campaign
against Maximus in the year 388, the emperor, admiring her zeal for Askecies and Virtue,
restored her possessions to her. She immediately began to give away her immense riches in alms
and works of mercy. She sold her properties in Thrace, Galatia, Capodosia, and Bithinia,
as well as her luxurious houses in Constantinople in order to build hostels everywhere for travelers,
hospitals, and churches, and a monastery built against the south gate of Saint Sophia's,
which gave shelter to more than 250 nuns. Firstly, her servants and kinswomen,
whom other women of high society soon joined.
Clad in poor clothing, her face without cosmetics, her body wasted by the vigils and prayers that
served her in place of food and drink, her heart at peace and her spirit a stranger to all
worldly curiosity, the saint was to all an image of Virtue itself. Despite the trials that she had
to endure, not a word of complaint ever passed her lips, and her charity extended to all,
worthy, and unworthy. She spent her whole life in constant and undistracted contemplation of Christ,
her eyes bathed in tears of compunction. The fame of her Virtue was so great that aged only 30,
she was ordained deaconess by the Holy Patriarch, Nectarios, and became his advisor in many ecclesiastical
matters. When Saint John Chrysostom succeeded Nectarios in the year 398, Olympias found in him not
only the spiritual father she desired, the authority in the interpretation of the scriptures,
the pastor who cared more for the whole church than for his own body, but also a companion and friend,
both in days of happiness and in the tribulations endured for the truth and right living.
She put herself at his service with zeal, providing all the saint's material needs and giving
alms widely as he prescribed. The only man allowed into Olympias' monastery, the Holy Bishop,
often went there to teach the nuns and to ordain many of his disciples deaconess.
After Saint John's exile to Armenia in the year 404, Olympias refused to recognize his successor
and undertook the defense of his cause, accused by prefect optatus of having caused a fire,
which breaking out in Saint Sophia's had destroyed the adjoining palace. She refused any concession
and had to pay a large indemnity. She then withdrew to Zizekis and after appearing again before the
prefect she was sent into exile to Nicomedia where Saint John Chrysostom sent her 17 wonderful letters
of consolation, exhorting her to endure the trials and injustice with faith and patience.
Through his encouragement Saint Olympias made the exile an opportunity for growth in patience
and humility. After having engaged in violent battles for the church, having instructed many women
on the path of virtue, having honored the clergy and placed herself at the service of bishops,
she gave her soul into God's hands in Nicomedia on the 25th of July in the year 408,
carrying off the crown of confessors of the faith. In conformity with her vow, her shrouded body was
given to the sea as it drew near to the monastery of St. Thomas of Brokty on the Asiatic coast of the
Bosphorus. An angel warned the abbot who went to find it and place it near the altar where it began to
work healings. The saint's monastery in Constantinople destroyed during the revolt of Nikitas in the year
532 was rebuilt by Justinian and her relics were translated there at the beginning of the 7th century
under the threat of Persian invasion. Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord,
Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.